good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I'm very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2022 2023
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from
the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series has focused on the use of
data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to
different themes in biomedical and
Health Sciences this year's theme is
data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where we will enjoy presentations such
as the one we're about to hear on
Fridays from leading thinkers about
issues promises opportunities and
hurdles associate shaded with
understanding the secondary health
effects of covet 19. these include
delayed Health checkups treatments
mental health drug abuse increased
obesity and the long lingering health
effects associated with the SARS
covid-19 virus
indeed as we are approaching here in
December we're approaching January where
our application cycle will complete but
right now we are accepting applications
we encourage Junior faculty members
working in the areas of such areas as
infectious diseases neurology
epidemiology clinical medicine
population Health as well as data
science machine learning AI statistics
and other relevant domains to consider
applying we believe this will be
exciting and exciting and engaging
program we're characterizing the
secondary health effects of covet
necessitates unique quantitative
approaches but also new
multi-disciplinary collaborations
participants selected for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab program will
leverage these presentations as vital
material for our culminating in-person
Grant project development Workshop to be
held at the lodge at St Edwards Park in
Seattle Washington in June of 2023.
today I am delighted to welcome our
speaker Dr Michael Lipton from Albert
Einstein Stein College of Medicine Dr
Lipton is a neuroradiologist and
neuroscientist and his professor at the
gross magnetic resonance Research Center
Department of Neurology at Albert
Einstein as well as the medical director
of MRI Services as at its University
Hospital on Montefiore Medical Center
both in New York City he divides his
professional time between clinical
practice of neuroradiology teaching and
research his translational research
broadly seeks to characterize brain
mechanisms linking environmental
exposures to brain dysfunction and to
understand how these relationships are
modified by individual characteristics
such as sex and genes and his research
program currently applies MRI to
characterize brain microstructure and
function in the context of repeated head
impacts in sports as well as the SARS
covid II infection and in aging
his work on the impact of heading soccer
balls and other things and brain
structure is funded by The Dana
Foundation the National Institutes of
Health and has received extensive
worldwide scientific and lay press
attention in continuing with this year's
2022-2023 biomedical data science
seminar series theme Michael's lecture
today is entitled neurocognitive decline
in young adults with mild covid-19
grounding assessment in pre-pandemic
data Dr lipton's research has
Illustrated that excessive excess
cognitive dysfunction has been
identified in older adult survivors of
covid-19 compared to other respiratory
infections SARS covet 2 may be thus
inversely impactful for the brain beyond
what causes acute stroke Etc and Etc
unrecognized brain effects of SARS covid
II infection may impact current brain
functioning and um uh pre-sage future
neurodegeneration and overall neurologic
dysfunction Dr Lipton will present the
approach he is taking which leverages
detailed pandemic neurocognitive and
imaging assessments to characterize
subclinical effects on brain structure
and function amongst a large cohort of
younger patients who experude mild
coveted symptoms as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for
recording via YouTube and if you're
watching on YouTube thank you so much
for joining us also our specially
selected
2022-2023 biomedical data science
Innovation lab participants and alumni
are encouraged to submit any questions
they have via the chat feature in their
Zoom sessions I will synthesize these
questions and ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so of the
lecture and with that Michael welcome we
are so excited to hear about uh your
work
thank you very much I appreciate the
invitation to speak to you and um I you
know at the outset I just want to sort
of set the stage that this is going to
be really a conceptual someone high
level talk about a study that uh I've
really just begun or at least begun the
post-covet phase of we're actively
enrolling participants and I'll share at
the end a little bit of preliminary data
but I'm really going to utilize a lot of
my previous work related to traumatic
injury to the brain as a context that I
think really informs a lot of important
considerations in doing this uh this
type of work so you know to people know
a lot or maybe they feel like they know
too much or have heard too much about
covid but in terms of the nervous system
you know we know since pretty early on
that there are neurological effects
uh there's been debates as to what the
mechanisms are going on in the brain but
you know certainly effects on smell
severe effects like Strokes cerebritis
uh have been an issue uh what is really
the the focus of of my work and I think
is as we get to less and less
um uh incidents of severe covid-19
disease what's much more of a concern is
persistent effects and what's come to be
called uh long covet now you know this
is a CDC slide which I actually think is
misleading because when they say one in
five adults uh we'll have a health
condition that might be related to their
previous covet 19. just to be clear that
doesn't mean one in five adults it means
one in five adults who had coveted 19.
so that certainly is a is a staggering
percentage but it doesn't mean one in
five in the population and you know this
is become an area that everybody just
really wants to you know jump on the
bandwagon and you can find so many
different resources talking about all
different kinds of multi-system effects
and you know talk about things like the
so-called parallel pandemic uh you know
really long covet is is really very much
in the Forefront I think it's important
because of its effects now and in the
brain in particular we're really
thinking about what are the longer term
implications
is really you know drives to the the key
question as to
how can you conduct a study that will uh
you know derive robust you know rigorous
reliable inferences about what is going
on in the brain that may explain the
kinds of clinical problems that we are
seeing people have it uh and in that
regard I wanted to outline a bunch of
challenges to think about and I put
these into two kind of gross categories
one is considerations related to
detecting the pathology and you know I
should uh just point out so I am a
clinical neuroradiologist I look at
images
and we use them for diagnosis but just
to be clear in covid in general in Long
covid in particular uh you know clinical
Imaging doesn't really offer us a whole
lot the brain looks pretty normal when
you look at these images and ultimately
we need to think about the fact that we
need to be able to look for small stuff
and I like to say that you know in the
brain that's one place for sure where
Size Doesn't Matter small things can
actually make a big difference in terms
of function and I will you know give you
some a more concrete information on this
but we're also interested in subtle
subclinical effects because those may
present longer term uh problems uh of
course things like measurement stability
uh mechanisms clinical significance and
then I have my confounding
column here where there are a few
different things to uh to think about
now in in terms of what I'll actually
cover I'm not going to talk about
measurement stability which is a very
important issue particularly in
neuroimaging but with any kind of
clinical measurement obviously if we're
looking at change over time which I will
get to we need to have a measurement
that doesn't vary more than the effect
that we're looking for
the other area that I won't touch on
that's extremely important in the study
of covid is diagnostic certainty or
uncertainty and what I mean here is
determining who's a control and who's a
patient because we're typically seeing
these people long after they've actually
had their infection and you know if you
look back to the early days of the
pandemic there was very little testing
being done you know I'm I was in ground
zero in New York for the covet pandemic
and you know SARS cov2 pcrs were hard to
come by people were hunkered down at
home so in terms of you know clarifying
who did and who didn't have an infection
and this only became more complicated
after the Advent of vaccination which is
misspelled I apologize that gave lots of
people who didn't have covid antibodies
it becomes a you know quite a challenge
so this is an important area and I'm
extremely grateful and indebted to my
co-pi Johanna Daly who's an infectious
disease physician and expert that's
helping us understand this but I'm not
going to get into those particulars I'm
really going to focus on these issues
related to measurement to detect the
disease try and connect it to mechanisms
in the brain that have clinical
significance and I'm going to talk about
some considerations related to variation
among individuals that's not related to
the disease
and confirmation of causation which we
need to think about
so the you know the general approach
that that I take in in my work which is
in many areas one of the areas that I
focus on most has been uh mild degrees
of traumatic injury particularly when
setting up Sports You Know Jack
mentioned heading in soccer or football
depending on where in the world you're
watching from
but the the end of the day uh the model
that we use is pretty generic
and this is an approach that's been used
to assess for example many environmental
exposures things like lead
radium asbestos
where we think about a Continuum that
starts on the left with exposure to
something might be covet as far as cov2
infection might be head impacts and we
end up on the far right in not everybody
in some subset with a clinical disease
and to get from the exposure to the
clinical disease that exposure which is
something outside of the patient has to
convert into what we refer to as an
internal dose and I'll talk about some
examples of what internal dose might be
it basically means the uh you know the
the
the perturbation that occurs inside of
the uh inside of the person and if
there's a sufficient internal dose we
then start to get a by a bio effective
dose which leads to bio effects meaning
actually changes in the biology if in
our case the brain which may or may not
lead to alterations and structure and
function and may or may not lead to
clinical disease moving from left to
right we see that there's an increasing
likelihood that the farther you get
along the Continuum that the effects are
going to persist and a decreasing
likelihood that there will be recovery
and so you know in the context if we
sort of fast forward into the future of
thinking about how to do something about
these types of processes other than just
describe them if we think about how we
might intervene to make a difference we
want to think about out doing something
that will impact these early bio effects
or minimize this bio-effective dose so
we don't get that far along the
Continuum I think that's why it's really
important to characterize these effects
when they are small when they are
subclinical so we have an opportunity to
identify the mechanisms and get to them
early so uh you know I've looked at this
extensively in the context of repeated
head impacts or heading in soccer and in
the bottom I've just sort of listed some
examples of each of these categories so
it's pretty straightforward that the
impact To The Head and the number of
impacts and the nature of those impacts
is the exposure the internal dose is
typically something that we're really
never going to measure effectively in
Vivo
and in the setting of trauma we're
thinking about things like stress and
strain on axons uh the bio-effective
dose is essentially when we get to the
level that there is something detectable
and this is really the sort of earliest
detectable phase which we want to be
able to
identify the those bio effects in the
setting of trauma will be things like
inflammation they will lead to
alterations of structure and function
that are less reversible like what we
call secondary taxonomy or disconnection
of axons and ultimately we get Frank
tissue injury and loss with changes to
brain function and things like
connectivity so this is the head injury
context and I'll come back to this but
just to at the outset put this in the
context of mild covet 19. I put some
candidates along the bottom so the
infection is what we would consider sort
of the exposure in this case and that
internal dose is the extent to which we
have uh you know virus or antigen
getting into the central nervous system
across the blood-brain barrier to
provoke a response and when that
responds in whatever way becomes
detectable uh that's really the what
we're detecting is that bio-effective
dose when there's a sufficient amount of
viral activity or challenge that can
provoke something adverse in the brain
that we can detect and those bio effects
will be across a range of potential
mechanisms which I've listed here
inflammation being a huge candidate
vascular effects Etc as you go farther
to the right the it's interesting that
the
likely altered structure and function
effects and clinical disease are going
to actually look very similar and and
this is a kind of a general pattern that
we're essentially looking at a process
of injury to the brain and at the end of
the day while there will be some
differences we're essentially looking at
similar endpoints now
if we think about the type of
Assessments which you know I'm going to
propose in particular Imaging for
assessment of covid-19 the blue box is
sort of the domain where Imaging is
likely to give us information
uh the Imaging effects will first become
detectable and relevant in the realm of
identifying that minimal bio effective
dose but things like the internal dose
we're probably never going to get to
with Enviro Imaging and certainly the
exposure the diagnosis of actual
infection is something that's happening
outside of image
so with that sort of overarching concept
I want to go through a few of the items
that I highlighted and the first which
is you know is very important is
detection it's looking for the small
stuff in the brain that may have
significant effects and to put that in
context I want to just present a um an
example which is an example that I use
frequently from my clinical experience
and this is related to traumatic brain
injury and I'm going to show you two
patients the first patient here is a man
who was in his I think he was in his
early 60s and he was in a motor vehicle
collision came into the emergency
department and the GCS for those who
aren't familiar with clinical neuro
assessment is Glasgow Coma Scale the
Glasgow Coma Scale score ranges from 0
to 15 and assesses how severely injured
the person is during the acute phase
suffice it to say this is considered a
severe injury this patient was
essentially comatose coming into the
emergency room excuse me a score goes
from 3 to 15. so this is this is a quite
a severe injury and in looking at this
picture which is a CT scan or CAT scan
of the head uh it's grossly abnormal
there's a large subdural hematoma
there's some bleeding in the brain or
around the brain quite abnormal
the next patient I want to show you
comes in with the same uh clinical
severity the glass of Coma Scale score
is six comatose this is a young woman
she was actually a second year law
student who was also in a motor vehicle
collision
and the difference is that her brain
looks totally normal no one could
convince me that there's anything
visible abnormal in this case now the
important point is that in the sort of
distal effect and the long-term outcome
the man on the left actually made a very
good recovery you know close to what his
Baseline was and the woman on the right
actually had to drop out of school and
never finished her degree because of her
injury and that really drives to the
question is if the brain looks so
abnormal on the left and so normal on
the right why is the person with the
normal looking brain having those
adverse effects and that really gets at
the point that what is going on here is
more than what we can see with this
simple clinical test and as I'll
describe it has to do with disruptions
of brain Network function
and it's what we call diffuse brain
injury and diffuse brain injury is a
term that's used in the setting of
trauma which I am going to use as an
example here but keep in mind that covid
is also a form of diffuse brain injury
and by diffuse brain injury what we mean
is that there are widespread microscopic
lesions in the setting of trauma
especially in the white matter although
not only
that the injury is not something like
you know if you think about breaking
your arm you fall down and it's broken
and you can take an x-ray picture and
you can see the full extent of the
injury in injury to the brain there's
actually an evolving impairment where
things mechanisms such as excitotoxicity
neuroinflammation over time will lead to
late effects like degeneration of
excellence and loss and violence
all of these things are going on at a
microscopic level
so anything that we might see on those
clinical Imaging tests is really just
the tip of the iceberg and you know I
really like the iceberg analogy because
the Lion's Share of the pathology and in
fact the pathology which not only is it
most of the pathology but it's really
the most important pathology that leads
to the types of outcomes that adversely
affect these individuals which are
impairment of cognitive function so
these are people who are not paralyzed
they're not blind they're not deaf but
they have significant difficulties with
cognitive function emotional regulation
much higher level functions which are a
consequence of disruption of brain
Network integrity and function and it
really
I don't want to skip over this too
quickly it really is the stuff that we
don't see that is most important
so to drive that home I want to get to
another couple of clinical examples to
talk a little bit about a technique and
imaging Technique we use and I'm not
going to get into a lot of details but I
want to show you another patient who had
a fall 15 feet onto the top of his head
and he had this cat scan on the day of
the injury and these if you can barely
see these little white spots there's a
little bleeding in his brain
he was watched in the hospital sent home
and he seemed to be okay but years later
was having some significant uh
difficulty with function now the
follow-up CAT scan which I'm not going
to show you would look normal these
areas of bleeding would no longer be
visible and in fact he had MRI studies
which look normal
and we applied a technique which I will
get to called diffusion tensor energy
and diffusion tryptography to be able to
essentially depict the white matter
connections that go through his corpus
callosum connecting the two cerebral
hemispheres and we can see those looking
from the top of the head on your left
and from the side on your right we can
see that there is a defect that's an
approximately the same location where
those little hemorrhages were what
happened was the connections which
should be present have degenerated over
time and that loss of connection we see
some part of it here
is what is responsible for his uh
overall functional situation so this is
a just a graphical way to a pick to
depict what is really going on at a
microscopic level
and to explain just very conceptually
why we use diffusion Imaging to detect
that small stuff that microscopic image
microscopic injury if we think about the
brain and in particular white matter in
the brain it is essentially bundles of
parallel structures these are cartoons
to represent axons or the processes that
transmit information from one neuron to
another and these axons are very small
if you had a single red blood cell you
could probably put 10 of them in
parallel through the diameter of that
red blood cell so really at the micro
micro level and what we detect with
diffusion MRI is the direction of
movement of molecular water through the
tissue and in the setting of these axons
these are essentially parallel barriers
to the movement of water such that the
movement of water will tend to follow
the orientation of the axons and this is
the basis for creating those nice
pictures where we can show where the
nerve fibers are going those red lines
you saw in those images are not axons
right they are just macroscopic
representations of the overall direction
of movement and we can do this because
the movement of water is very organized
or what we call
unidirectional or anisotropic and it
leads to a scenario where we can
characterize that direction if you have
an injury where you lose some of those
structures those axons degenerate or you
lose myelin then you have a much more
random direction of water movement or
water diffusion it becomes much more
random or what we call isotropic
diffusion and this is an abnormality
this abnormality prevents you from
tracing those fibers but more
importantly we can actually
characterize or quantify diffusion using
various parameters and I'm being very
superficial here one of the summary
parameters we can use is something
called fractional anisotropy which is
very high it's fa for short it's very
high in the setting of this normal white
matter microstructure and it becomes low
in the setting of injury of any kind
whether it's due to trauma whether it's
due to infection or ischemia because of
the loss of that microstructure so we
can use this measure this parameter
derived from specific types of MRI to
characterize whether we have a more
normal or less normal white matter and
so a way to apply that is
in this example where I'm showing you a
patient who also had a traumatic injury
I was a young high functioning person
who had some significant uh problems
functioning in her ivy league College
after a spring break accident her MRI
images look normal but when we compare
the measurement of that fa in her brain
indicated in this red circle to the
range in a group of normal people which
is between these two black bars we see
that the range of normal and the median
in that normal group is much higher than
this patient so the fa is lower that is
this scenario where we have lost some of
that structure so this is a way of
quantitatively getting at an injury that
is otherwise essentially invisible right
so this is a way to detect that
microscopic injury
the next thing I wanted to get at in
terms of detection
is the issue of the clinical
significance of these types of Imaging
findings and how we can use them to
implicate something important uh as well
as something that tells us about
mechanisms going on in the brain and
importantly in the examples I showed you
those were first of all you know to be
quite clear those are anecdotal those
are individual patient cases I I painted
a nice story but at the end of the day
how do you really confirm that what
we're looking at means what we think it
means and so you know it's interesting
that this picture on the right I don't
some of you may have seen this maybe
you've all seen it before this was is an
old spread in Life Magazine where they
mix up a bunch of people uh many of
these are regular productive people I
think authors and the rest of them equal
numbers of each are uh people who
committed horrendous crimes and the
question is by looking at these can you
really tell who's who uh and you know
that that was the the output there but
the question I'm really trying to get at
is when you have a picture what does it
mean what you think it means and it's
not a question of whether the finding is
normal or not uh so pictures don't lie
now you certainly can have uh Imaging
findings which are misleading or are
misrepresented that other issues with
the analysis but if we just take for
example that an Imaging finding such as
this this is from a paper early paper
that we published looking at very mild
traumatic brain injury in a relatively
small cohort and we found areas such as
this one this is not the only one but
this area in the lateral prefrontal
cortex where that same Imaging measure
that I think a was much lower in the
patients than controls and these were
people who very few had loss of
consciousness it was a very mild entry
cohort so we can look at this and say
that's nice and you know there's
extensive reproduction of findings like
this across many independent samples so
it's not really a question as to whether
this is a real finding it's a question
as to whether this is the finding that
tells us something about function in
this group and so in this study what we
did was also assess cognitive function
and I'm just showing you one little
piece which is a test called The Maze
task where healthy people can complete
this task in fewer trials with uh you
know with a shorter time and on these
plots what we're looking at is that the
uh
the number of trials in the bottom and
the completion time in the top is uh on
the vertical axis and the fractional
anisotropy is on the horizontal axis
so the gray triangles are the TBI
patients the black circles or the
healthy controls you can see that
there's General separation in terms of
both the fractional and isentropy value
as well as the cognitive parameter so
this gave us you know some confidence
that we are seeing a an Imaging effect
which seems to be related to a cognitive
effect
but if you are honest about this and we
try to be honest about our findings
um this is really what's going on so we
have two groups right our healthy people
and the sort of pink tan color and our
concussed group and the blue color and
what we've done is we've looked at their
group assignment whether they do or do
not have the concussion and we've looked
at how that's related to things going on
in the brain with MRI and then the
longer arrows going to the far right how
that's related to brain function so I I
diagram it this way to make it very
clear that these are two parallel
assessments
and all we are saying in such an example
is that there are both associations of
the state of being concussed with
something measurable in the brain and
with something measurable in terms of
cognitive brain function
the question is does this allow us to
infer a mechanism meaning does it allow
us to infer
that what we detect in the brain is
actually the cause of that cognitive
problem and the answer is that it
doesn't uh it is certainly consistent
with that but as We Know
we can have parallel correlations in
many situations which don't necessarily
lead to a causative effect and to get to
this type of causative effect where it's
the status of being injured or not
and the cognitive effect that it so to
speak goes through what's happening in
the brain what we see in the brain is
truly a mechanistic effect that really
requires some specific approaches which
I'm not I'm really not an expert in this
but I'm not going to have time to get
into it at all but I want people to
think about it in terms of the types of
studies that we're dealing with uh not
again trauma is just the context I'm
using and I will Circle back to covet
but in the case of covid if you want to
make an inference that you're really
identifying the mechanism in the brain
that's responsible for the adverse
outcome you need approaches that can
address that
[Music]
um
the next
item that I want to
move to is this issue of confounding
things that what I mean by confounding
here is elements that may
lead us to detect something that we
could potentially attribute to an effect
of let's say trauma or covet uh but it's
actually due to something else and this
really is most pertinent in the realm of
inter-individual variation which can be
many different things and you know this
really takes me back to you know
earliest days of my work with trauma and
is extremely relevant to covet where we
could find all of these findings that
seemed very compelling in groups of
people who came into the emergency room
follow the concussion and we attributed
those to concussion but at the end of
the day
we didn't know these people before they
had those injuries and without knowing
the person before uh it's really not
possible explicitly to know whether what
you identify in the brain is a
consequence of the injury that you are
studying or that you are assessing in a
patient and in the clinical context we
go back to the history and there are
previous medical records Etc because
things like their developmental
trajectory comorbid disease substance
exposure did they have another traumatic
brain injury in the past etc etc gives
you this sort of uh you know ball of
string that you are now putting under
the microscope so to speak to understand
what is going on and in the context of a
you know again in a clinical assessment
you would look at the whole picture of
the patient in the context of a research
study we would try to understand what
are those relevant individual
characteristics and we would look at how
they affect the relationships that we
see between being a patient or a control
having an effect in your brain and
having an outcome so this would be a
layer that would be put on top of that
place we left a minute ago trying to
look at whether brain effects mediate
the association between exposure and
outcome and we would add to that
something which we might look at as
effect modification or something along
those lines of how some feature whether
it is age or sex or a gene or something
else might account for these differences
if we have a systematic variation
between our two groups then we can be
sort of let down the Garden Path and
make a false inference the question
becomes in the context of a study such
as a study of the effects of mild
covid-19 or a study of the effects of
mild trauma does this really work does
this really address the question and you
know I'll maintain that we can do this
and it's
it's better than not taking this
approach
But ultimately that sort of previous
unknown uh and the extent to which that
might vary across participants in a
clinical study is a pretty difficult
problem to surmount and this really gets
to you know why it is that I'm actually
interested in soccer or heading you know
it is first of all a form of head injury
so that's important it's very common
about one in 20 people on the planet
currently play soccer so as a result it
has significant Public Health
implications but the real truth of the
matter is that my interest in soccer
started not because of that public
health concern but really started
because soccer uniquely gives us the
ability to measure or at least estimate
exposure and what that means is that
that what came before I can characterize
in a way that I can't in someone who
simply walks in the door without my
knowing what happened before so in the
in the context of soccer what what I
mean is that we can use various
techniques and there are different
approaches to looking at how much
exposure to head impacts these
individuals had over the previous
whatever period of time
and use that ability to characterize
exposure to eliminate some of the
uncertainty about how our controls
patients Etc actually uh May differ from
each other
and I want to give you an example of how
that allows us then to look at other
Salient differences between those groups
so in this example
um
I'm showing you let's see it should
start now
so I'm showing you two
brains and they have a bunch of blue uh
blobs on them those blue areas are areas
that we are suggesting represent areas
of injury uh they're areas where higher
exposure to heading is associated with
lower fa
and the groups however these are two
separate groups which are groups of the
same size the same age they're matched
one to one for age and they're also
matched one to one for exposure so
there's an equal range of heading in
both groups but we're showing you that
heading uh with the same amount of
exposure has a different effect in these
two groups and the thing that differs
between these two groups is that one of
these groups is all men and one is all
women and it you know it turns out that
the women are the group that has more of
these abnormalities so this finding is
telling us that we have some evidence
that if we hold the exposure equal uh
that women seem to have more
vulnerability than men now
in a similar vein we can look at other
individual features in this case we're
looking at the E4 Epsilon for allele of
the April lipoprotein e Gene which is a
bad actor in many different disorders
including traumatic brain injury more
severe traumatic brain injury at least
and in this study a student in my lab
Leanne Hunter looked at the
interaction of heading exposure and this
Gene with respect in this case to verbal
memory function so the blue bars are
people who have minimal exposure to
headache and the green bars are people
who have the highest exposure to
headache and these are you know
otherwise we're accounting for things
like sex and age education in these
assessments the difference between the
first pair of bars on the left is that
those individuals do not have this bad
actor allele and those on the right do
and the message is that if you have
exposure that is higher
uh you don't really look very different
in terms of verbal memory relative to
people who have lower exposure there's
no significant difference the only
similarly even if you have a high
exposure if you don't have that bad
actor Gene you don't look different from
those who don't have the Gene and have
low exposure it's only the combination
of highest exposure and this Gene that
confers the risk for adverse effects on
memory so being able to understand
uh that sort of
picture of what these people were like
before becomes very important for
teasing out things such as these other
individual characteristics now the other
thing that is really important in the
context of coven which I will come back
to is the whole issue of causation
so we talked about setting up an
analysis in this case I'm looking at
people who play soccer and don't hit the
ball much and people who had the ball a
lot and we see that there are different
trajectories of brain effects and
cognitive effects let's say blue is
worse and you know Green is is better
the question becomes how do we know that
being someone who does a lot of heading
is again is the cause so previously we
looked at mediation to try and connect
what's in the brain
wedge it into that Continuum from
exposure to outcome but but a separate
question that still pertains is is this
really a causative effect and as you
know pre-clinical researchers will know
that the only way to really confirm
causation is to have an experimental
paradigm and you know that really begs
the question as to can we ever do an
experiment on traumatic brain injury we
can't bring Volunteers in and pay them a
lot of money so we can hit them in the
head but we do have people who are going
to repeatedly hit themselves in the head
over time
and if we look at those individuals not
just once but if we look at them over
time and if we characterize the exposure
over time
we can then look at how the amount of
exposure impacts change in the brain
measure change in cognition and how
those two interact with each other
differentially between people who have
low exposure and high exposure and so to
show you some example of of that this is
a an analysis that was done by a medical
student who's still thankfully working
in my lab volume Charney who looked on
the left at fa so we looked at
quantifying the volume of fa within the
brain which was abnormal and we
looked at how that effect
was different at
month zero and month 24 of a two-year
follow-up period and we split our sample
into two groups they were each measured
at 0 and 24 months the group on the left
were people who over that 24 months
increased the amount of heading that
they did and the group on the right were
either flat or decreased and we see that
the change in abnormal fa is going up in
the people who have an increase in
exposure whereas those who either
decrease or maintain their exposure
during that period of time do not have a
significant effect
having this longitudinal piece really
gives us a much stronger footing in
terms of implicating uh
the causation of that exposure during
that period to these effects and
similarly looking at verbal memory in
this case in the list learning task
these are the same sample divided into
three separate groups low moderate and
high in terms of the amount of heading
and pink is zero months blue is 24
months and we can see if you look at the
at the medians here that there is not
much change and this was not a
significant change in memory performance
if anything it's a non-significant
increase which is probably a practice
effect that we expect to see when we
give a similar task multiple times but
in the highest exposure group we see a
clear and significant decline certainly
overlap but there seems to clearly be a
decline in that or restricted to that
high exposure so this kind of design
allows us to say injury Imaging
cognition is actually potentially a
causative continuum
so this really gets to what I was asked
to speak about which is coven on the
right and the question is what is you
know soccer heading have to do with
covet and I think that there are a lot
of parallels in terms of the design of
the experiments in terms of what we know
about the effects of mild covet on the
brain there's lots of literature by the
way regarding acute severe effects and
severe covet
there's very little on post-acute
effects in mild covet and those are all
uh case reports or case Series this case
Series in particular was quite upfront
about the fact that they simply had a
post-covered clinic and they couldn't
say anything about causation because
they only saw these people after the
fact
the the one you know clear outlier in
terms of that that sea of anecdotal
reporting is the well-known UK biobank
study which first was a preprint that it
was published in nature uh in February
this year
I guess it was published in March
um and the UK biobank study is important
because they had uh this is a really
impressive setup which we don't really
have the kind of uh National Health
infrastructure as they do in the UK with
the National Health Service but they had
a cohort of 785 people of which 400 had
coveted very few were hospitalized and
they were in a natural history study
where they were having assessments over
time
so MRI biomarkers cognition and the key
here is that they were assessed before
their potential exposure to covet also
because of the UK Health System they
were able to determine uh quite well
what the SARS cov2 status was and even
after excluding the people who were
hospitalized they were able to find a
suite of structural brain findings some
cognitive effects and a clear Divergence
and this is important from patients who
had pneumonia or influenza suggesting
that there really is something about
covid-19 that is affecting the brain
this is again it's longitudinal pre-post
assessments where they can quantify
change in the context of different
groups of individuals and really begin
to attribute
a causative inference now a key
limitation here
from my point of view is that they're
looking at an older cohort
it's also not clear they only had 15 who
were hospitalized but it wasn't clear
that there was not potentially more
severity in this group but it's a large
sample now in terms of what we are doing
this is the title of my new study so
having studied large numbers of healthy
young people
for the past
15 years
we have a lot of individuals who we had
characterized very well over the
pre-pandemic period we have MRI
biospecimens extensive cognitive and
behavioral characterization and so we
designed a study based on a small
preliminary data set which I'll share
with you in a second where we are going
to specifically look at an age band
which is not children but is really the
adult population below the age range of
the UK biobank study we have fortunately
plenty of female as well as male
participants our sample is also
different because in the Bronx we're one
of the most racially ethnically diverse
locations in the United States and we're
going to look at a total of 140
individuals 70 of them will have
evidence of SARS come B2 infection these
people all had mild disease and we
carefully exclude people who were
hospitalized or had other manifestations
of severe disease
preliminary findings such as findings
from this limbic orbital frontal
projection were that in terms of brain
Imaging measures we found effects on
cortical thickness and orientation
dispersion index which is a diffusion
measure that's an analogous in some ways
to fractional at isotropy these two
measures are also the measures that were
identified in the UK biobank study and
what we find is that in controls there
is either there is a minimal increase
and in the SARS cov2 patients there is a
decrease which actually reached
statistical significance and I want to
be clear the 140 individuals is our
ongoing perspective study uh the people
that I'm reporting on on the right are
going to be part of that study but this
analysis is only six infected
individuals and 14 controls so this is a
tiny pilot sample and we did not find
significant effects on cognition
although we did find trends that
suggested impairment and that notion by
the way that we have an Imaging effect
uh without a corresponding
cognitive effect really points to the
possibility that what we may be
detecting is a subclinical uh
degree of disease where we can see
something going on in the tissue before
we can actually see an overt
manifestation and it's important to keep
in mind that in these individuals if we
simply looked at their performance or
even their brain measures relative to
Norms they're all going to fall in the
normal range solidly
it's only the ability to look at post
covid to pre-covet and that difference
that allows us to pull out these
findings so in terms of this study again
we're not going to take and we really
can't take an approach where these are
the good behaving controls and these are
the bad behaving unmasked people who got
coveted as we all know and it can't work
if we take this sort of parallel Imaging
and cognition approach our approach is
going to be a longitudinal approach
where we will actually look repeatedly
over time so that we can see how change
over time in MRI and cognition
accounting for individual
characteristics which get that an
important factor which is the stress
Etc of the pandemic which affects both
of these groups by including those
measures we can hopefully somehow
account for that and attribute our
inferences of within individual change
relative to exposure meaning non-covid
or covid to something that really
reflects the effects of the disease and
so this is the design where you know in
the process of uh running subjects even
today and uh you know hopefully we'll be
having uh you know more uh concrete data
to share in the coming years so that was
my uh introduction to the study I just
want to uh carefully make sure that I
acknowledge all of the people on the
team uh running and designing and
overseeing the study as well as the
funding sources that both helped us
develop the cohorts
prior to the covet pandemic that we
depend on as well as the more recent uh
funding that allowed us to really do
this current perspective study so thank
you Michael thank you very much as you
were presenting some of your work and I
just kind of kept up coming up in my
mind about studies that have included
more than two time points and it sounds
like that's the study that you have
going on now and just inspired by work
that goes on in TBI you know very often
you don't have a pre-scanned you know
Baseline they've been concussed if
you're fortunate enough to get them
within 72 hours you know what their
acute phase is and maybe you'll scan
them six months later or something but
you never really know what they were
like before the injury unless it's a
very
circumstantial or just fortuitous kind
of effect like for example the folks at
the UK biobank had opportunity to go
back and find those people that had
already been scanned and they said hey
would you get scanned again you're able
to then go and do it it makes it a
challenge
because as you know traumatic brain
injury is highly variable depends on the
size of the injury the type of you know
how the injury occurred the location
coup and Contra coup effects and stuff
um covid I imagine is likewise very
similar and I as you were talking about
kind of quantifying the the the the dose
or the impact the basically the effect
it's you know very often in TBI that's
sort of a direct function of the
biophysics of the brain
slopping around in your in a rigid
enclosure in covid how do you get a
sense of what that level of exposure is
you know either you have it or you
didn't have it but you don't get it by
degree so it seems and we also don't
know if there's
um any particular neural systems
although you alluded to possibly some in
the limbic system that may be more
sensitive are you finding any from your
initial analyzes are you finding any
particular neural systems or fasciculi
that may be more sensitive than others
in the presence of covet and how it how
how do you what do you make of that
yeah so uh you know our sample is very
small uh but it's intriguing how the the
location of the findings really lines up
with other things that have been
reported and you know I describe the UK
biobank study because it's really the
you know the most robust Imaging study
but if you've Additionally you know if
you look at the autopsy series and more
severe covid so there does really seem
to be a predominant distribution
involving uh orbital frontal Factory
cortex limbic regions seem to be
strongly effective you know it's kind of
interesting I presume you're telling the
whole story I mean yeah
well further research is needed right
but uh you know certainly you know from
being something that's respiratory that
gets you know probably enters your brain
through you know an olfactory Roots
possibly
um you know it might not be overly
surprising that that's where those are
the early effects right they're going to
first hit olfactory areas and getting
limbic areas is probably the next you
know path down the down the the system
so that's probably an exciting way to to
push on that
um one of the other things I was going
to ask you is are you already thinking
about after it looks like you're going
to scan people out to 36 months or so do
you think that you'd ever go back follow
you know basically weights five years or
so or ten years and ask them to come
back and see if there's been any further
degeneration much like in that case that
you showed
um where somebody you know two and a
half years later really was having
problems and you saw further
degeneration would you would you
entertain that
so I I think that you know that's
extremely important and the you know one
of the one of the limitations is that
you know the funding mechanisms I do
with a very short Horizon and I think
what you need to really think about here
is that uh
we you know if we see effects in the
brain and we see effects you know do or
don't see effects on cognition but even
if those effects are subclinical
the really the the most important
question after people's you know sort of
immediate level of functioning is what
does this mean for the future in the
longer term and the big you know one of
the big concerns that you know we and
others have voiced is that this may be
uh an inciting exposure for Accelerated
neurodegeneration in order to see that
you need to follow people much longer so
you know it's really important that and
this by the way is true in TBI as well
even though it's not being done
um and it I think part of the reason
it's not being done is it's difficult to
do but it's also difficult to you know
run a program when you're funding
increments are you know limited uh three
to five years
yeah keeping keeping the term is really
important it's vital and keeping the
attention of the NIH that long is uh is
a challenge but it's so important and
you're absolutely right and it we just
don't know if a TBI that you incurred
when you were 19
doesn't you know kind of just linger and
then re-emerge when you're in your
mid-60s as something that looks like
Alzheimer's disease we just don't know
but we just don't have the timeline and
the funding across that timeline to be
able to follow those kinds of things up
but it's so important and it will be
important in the context of of kovitz
effects on the brain too and so I wish
you all the luck in the world on on this
study and I really hope that um there
will be that extra longitudinal
component um so you can bring people
back because this could be a very
important study much like the UK biobank
study will be in a few years so
uh Michael thank you so very much for
sharing your your uh perspectives with
us um this is the the role of covet in
the brain is very very important and you
are doing really cutting edge work here
and so thank you for sharing it with us
I want to thank everybody who joined us
this will be our last seminar series
installment for 2022 so we'll be taking
a little break for the holiday period
um we welcome uh those uh people who are
junior faculty working at the interface
of covid-19 research um with interest in
data science and data scientists
themselves to apply for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab program and
uh in the meantime everyone have a
wonderful holiday season with your
friends and your family and we will see
you again next year and finally Michael
thank you very very much we really
appreciate it thank you
have